haha the Joe Rogan experience we
definitely go down a bunch of different
rabbit holes like we did um we've had a
lot of like some of the protein
researchers come on and talk about some
of that stuff like dr. Stu Phillips our
professors - Phillips professor Tom
Lehman professor hos do you mean by
proteins toughly different qualities of
protein yeah they're doing like the
protein research they're kind of the
guys who are on the doing some of the
more recent research and looking at like
well what are our protein needs for I
across like a variety of Ages as well as
when you introduce athletics and then
like what does the quality versus or
like I guess maybe the best way to look
at is like the bioavailability of
different protein sources and things
like that and I think there's a you it
seems like something that we we'd have
figured out already but there's I guess
some nuance with that even and now we're
there they're saying that there's
probably reason to believe that our our
recommendations should be higher than
what they have been historically
especially for athletes and elderly
folks and but you mean the RDA yeah yeah
their RDA as it currently stands is
basically just to prevent disease right
mm-hmm yeah something like that and I
think they're I think they maybe are
learning more too about just kind of
what role protein plays in bone health -
as opposed to just cuz people think of
protein as just this building block for
muscle but there's a lot that goes into
it with with bone bone health as well so
those guys that were really interesting
to hear hear about and we've done a lot
of stuff with ranchers and some of the
like the savory salads and folks come on
the show and talk about kind of that
practice versus kind of your standard
agricultural production methods and
things like that savory style you mean
Joel Salatin what did what is savory
like Allan savory so we've had Allan
savory Joel Salatin will Harris from
white oak pastures on Bobby Gill he's
part of the savory Institute come on I
just kind of share with us like kind of
where that stuff is axe I think there's
a lot of guesswork and unanswerable
questions at this point with with that
some of that stuff cuz we're projecting
like you know way down the road with
some of this stuff are you talking about
the difference between grain fed versus
grass-fed meat yeah and most
specifically with those guys to just
like kind of what it's doing to the soil
health in the soil quality mm-hmm so one
thing that I've learned that was
interesting was that I mean we kind of
start to
like throw a lot of these different like
quote-unquote regenerative type
regenerative type practices into one egg
bucket or one category when in reality
there's a lot of different variants
within them so someone can say like over
generative agriculture is gonna save the
planet and then someone will go dig up a
bunch of studies that show like well no
it actually doesn't do anything and then
like yeah I'm confusing that because
Chris Kresser is all in on this
regenerative agricultural thing but it
has there it's a real evidence that you
can have a zero carbon gain yeah I mean
it's that's the that's the the the net
positive the idea is that if you use
regenerative agriculture meaning the
animals graze there there's you're not
talking to mono crop environments that
these cows graze on open fields of grass
and then they [ __ ] all over the place
and then you know that that [ __ ] becomes
manure and that this actually helps the
plant life grow and all this stuff sort
of it all becomes a part of a cycle you
had this regenerative practice is
actually instead of raising the carbon
footprint it actually makes a carbon
neutral footprint yeah yeah and I think
where sometimes it gets confusing is if
you go and you just look at studies on
regenerative agriculture you get a lot
of mixed information so what I was told
and I'm still kind of going down this
rabbit hole and the way I like to look
at all these type of things is I try to
like look at one side of the story and
then look to the other side and see
where the counters are to that and just
kind of go back and forth until you hit
a dead end and then you know if you hit
a dead end like oh that's where you're
at for now until you've something else
gets introduced and where I got to now
is okay I think of as maybe will Harris
told us this that when you're looking
for these studies on kind of what
practice is gonna be good in terms of
like soil regeneration you have to look
up a DAP t'v multi paddock grazing
because if you look up like holistic or
regenerative agriculture you're gonna
get a whole mess of like different
ranges or different types of it and you
know some are effective some aren't so
it's really hard to kind of piece out
you know who's got the accurate stuff
and not and I mean I think ultimately
some of this stuff is we just don't know
yet it was the one who that's most
just an adaptive multi paddock grazing
what does that mean it just means like
your instead of kind of your your it's a
rotational grazing from what I
understand but you're kind of moving the
the herd along to these different
products and then they're like you know
they're doing their thing you know what
would you consider like a natural way
likely would have been before we came in
and shot all the Buffalo and all that
stuff and then they're rotating it so
the way I've been under I've understood
it like the more of those paddocks you
can get the better because then you're
letting the the soil and the and
everything in there like really heal and
and develop that deep root system as
well as some of that microbiome like all
the insects and things that would be in
there right and all that stuff so you
would need massive amounts of land and
massive amounts of areas for them to
graze I think I yeah I mean I think you
would need I think the more the better
is probably the way to look at it but
hopefully the the soil biologists aren't
yeah I'm sure they are we apologize in
advance but like the interesting thing
though is like I mean I think there's a
lot of work to be done in looking to
this and finding out the best way to
maybe utilize it but the thought the
part that I thought was really
interesting is with the will Harris
white oak pastures thing they just I
think this studies maybe over utilized
by by like the the Pro regenerative a
multi paddock group to a degree because
it's like it's what they have and it's
what they're looking for they're looking
for a specific answer meaning this is
good this is the way we found a way
where you can eat meat and not feel bad
yeah yeah and it's the thing that's
compelling about that study to me is the
the way it kind of happened was
essentially what happened was will
Harris and white oak pastures they were
they were raising raising animals for
for epic bark like that that was one of
their buyers and epic bar got acquired
by I think was General Mills and so
General Mills looked at what epic bar
was claiming when they were the
independent and they were saying like
our stuff is regenerative ours you know
you eat you buy our product and you're
giving back versus taking kind of a
mindset and I think General Mills was
skeptical about that so they spent I
think was like 80 thousand dollars to go
in and have a study done on on will
Harris's
white oaks pasture to really see if they
could back that claim up and they went
in and they did the study and it
actually showed like on net carbon
sequestration versus like they weren't
even neutral they actually pulled in
more than they put out so this is from
epics particular type of farming that
they at least a white oaks pasture so I
mean again that's one specific situation
or one specific environment or area so I
think where people run into maybe a
potential problem is can we extrapolate
that forward to other areas are we gonna
get that same result or is it gonna be
different right that's what's important
too I mean it and it really is important
to look at that honestly mm-hmm because
even though you do have this one area is
that because of the environment where
this farm is taking place is because the
particular soil soil quality like what
are the factors that allow them to have
so it's it it actually takes carbon out
of the atmosphere like a certain
percentage so instead of adding carbon
it actually removes some yeah cuz I
guess the the way was described to me is
that the inputs of that type of system
are so low that like you're not look is
if you look at just a normal like
agricultural setup you know you have all
these inputs of like manure and all
these other things that are gonna add to
that then that net a factor that that
that net negative effect of animal
agriculture so when you reduce the
inputs down to next to nothing because
your inputs are all kind of just
manpower where you're moving these
things around or letting the natural
course of things happen all the time
that's where you can maybe minimize some
of these like I guess put you may be
called out to get tertiary damage of
animal agriculture but you know I think
I think we probably have a lot to learn
and stuff with that stuff too but it's
it's one of the things when I think
about it's like it
hopefully we're spending a lot of time
looking at that stuff because if they're
right about the number of harvests we
have left I think board of estimate we
have a 60 harvests left
I mean clearly regardless of whether
you're vegan carnivore or somewhere in
between
you know we need quality soil right
right what about hydroponic because I
know that there are some large-scale
hydroponic operations that are growing
vegetables and things on those lines
and some people think that there's real
promise in that because you're not
you're not using soil at all you're not
using you're not devastating they're
already depleted ground soil and you
also don't need to do all the the
harmful things that are involved in mono
crop agriculture right like the the
devastation on the wildlife the
displacement of wildlife pesticides
combines they're indiscriminately
indiscriminately chewing up small
rodents and bugs and rabbits and
anything else that gets caught in their
blades yeah yeah you know that'd be
interesting I don't know a whole lot
about it other than what it is so I mean
I'm all for solutions yeah somebody sent
me a link to something that some
indication that there there might be
some promise and hydroponic agriculture
but so but the thing about this whole
idea was the name of the farm were that
this was done where there's light oak
white are catchers is that sustainable
like nationally might forget about
globally ability even nationally in
terms of like the the needs that people
have for for beef I mean we we use so
much beef in this country yeah I don't
know for sure like what the scalability
of that would be my guess is like at
this point it would be because it's
pretty small like even from a percentage
standpoint of what is being how much of
that type of process is being used it's
like a single percentage or something
like that so we're all grass fed meat
right all grass stream yeah meat is like
less than 3% yeah so it seems like we'd
have a long ways to go
but I mean I guess the the counter to
that would also be were essentially
going back to what we would have been
doing historically mm-hmm and so it's
not necessarily like reinventing the
wheel as much as it is just saying okay
what we did here obviously is not
sustainable or potentially not
sustainable so let's look at well what
did we do to get back to where we were
before
I guess maybe is the way to look at that
but
[Applause]